things are looking really really really
bad for Rudy Guiliani
- of Rudy Giuliani's key employees have
been arrested for their work in
connection to Donald Trump's Ukraine
scandal and Rudy Giuliani himself is now
under criminal investigation it was a
big weekend that's for sure
the two guys were talking about our Lev
harness and Igor Froman they are
Associates of Rudy Giuliani Rudy
Giuliani is of course Trump's personal
lawyer or is he more on that a little
bit later and they were arrested just
before leaving the country on one-way
plane tickets now isn't that such an
amateur mistake you don't buy a one-way
ticket if you're trying to flee from
potential criminal charges you buy a
round-trip ticket pretend that you have
every intention of coming back to the
United States and then just don't use
the return it's an incredibly amateur
move that these two guys did in any case
their arrests are for a scheme that
violates campaign finance laws it
relates to the pressuring of Ukraine to
investigate and smear Joe Biden as we've
been following for weeks now
the charges are for illegal campaign
donations and it is all very very dirty
so understand that the role of these two
guys they're sort of the equivalent of
trumps Watergate henchmen they don't
work for Trump they work for the guy
that works for Trump in this case Rudy
Giuliani and it's all starting to look
and sound and smell and feel more and
more like Watergate every day in many
ways they were trying to leave the
country and were arrested literal flight
risks trying to escape justice for their
potential crimes carried out in service
to their boss Rudy Giuliani who is of
course doing Donald Trump's dirty work
and then as if that wasn't bad enough
that gets us to Rudy Giuliani himself we
learned that Rudy is under federal
criminal investigation for his Ukraine
dealings New York federal prosecutors
are now investigating Rudy Giuliani
criminally to see what lobbying laws if
any were broken Rudy Giuliani asked
about it of course
oh nothing to see here it's all nonsense
I'm doing everything fine it's all on
the up and up and now we will have to
wait and see will rudy giuliani end up
charged which would be just delightful
if indeed his actions are worthy of
criminal charges we don't really know
that much as of right now into about
this criminal probe into Rudy Giuliani
we don't know how advanced it is we
don't know how long it's been going on
we don't know where whether Rudy
Giuliani will end up charged and in so
for what but what is happening right
away and this was predictable i tweeted
about this just a few days ago what is
happening right now is that all of a
sudden Donald Trump is not sure anymore
whether Rudy Giuliani is still his
lawyer it's kind of weird right sounds
like a joke but I tweeted last week half
jokingly that this was going to happen
and it is and we're going to talk about
that after the break make sure you're
following me on Twitter at D Pakman
follow the show on Twitter at David
Pakman show and make sure that you're
following us on Twitter tonight s--
presidential debate a Democratic primary
presidential debate at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman I hope to see you there